she talked to a priest the priest went
with Holy Wood or something did some
prayers but then it didn't work when she
came back again there was the atmosphere
she she she says that the house was
still really heavy the atmosphere there
and uh after we became Christians then
she just went over with some pastors
they prayed they anointed the house they
break the course we still have that
house why do you think the uh the
blessing didn't take because I believe
like there are some some things
specifically that you have to break in a
house this is why understanding the
spiritual realm is so important right
it's not just like going there and
blessing this place I believe blessing
is a powerful things but there are
certain things in the spiritual real
like the same thing that we did in the
entrance of the house there was a portal
there that have to be closed there is a
portal there that the cords have to be
broken specifically in that place and
play the blood of Jesus and close those
things and rebuke the evil forces that
were inside of that house